hello there reject nation today
we're gonna check out spiderman no way
home gag reel and behind the scenes but
before we go into that the reason i'm
doing my terrible rick impression
because i want to shout out today's
video sponsor which is the walking dead
no man's land the official mobile role
play game for amc's the walking dead no
man's land immerses you in the world of
the walking dead over thousands of hours
of content across multiple game modes
including story based missions pulled
from the show itself second half of the
final season is airing right now which
means new game content after each new
episode i just think this is what
someone in the show sounds like yep that
means new playable characters new
weapons missions and events ripped
straight out of the show every move you
make has consequences including those
voices so it's the perfect way to put
your zombie apocalypse skills to the
test go lone wolf like greg alba or join
other survivors in guild challenges the
choice is yours you can download the
game today by hitting our special link
in the description box so scanning that
nifty qr code on screen and when you use
promo code the real rejects it's in all
caps you'll receive 40 michonne tokens
plus her signature katana now through
march 31st no man's land is available
free for ios and android so once this
video's done you know what to do that's
not how you do it
you know what to do
[Music]
hey
what's going on guys it's jacob and zade
here
we're about to show you the bloopers
sometimes movie making seems very
serious but a lot of times
comedy gold happens
well there's a lot of falling and
swearing i hope that they'll bleep that
out
[Music]
[Laughter]
blooper reel i think it's time to go
roll it
nice
feels like something out of euphoria for
some reason prop comedy let's save me mj
yikes
oh wow
okay
[Laughter]
have you been rolling this off
hey
hey holland
here buddy let me help you here
[Laughter]
keep the seals tight that's right he did
sorry
oh my god
there's other nets out there i wonder
what they're like what if there's one
where we don't even live in the same
same neighborhood or like the same state
like
that and it's like nebraska and you're
[Laughter]
you got a spider web on you that's
because i'm sprite
you do it
right there
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
there's a that's gotta hurt electric man
a sand man there's a dinosaur man
there's an octopus man
and then there's this old man
[Laughter]
yes
sorry
whatever
there's
wait wait wait i love you guys
okay okay go from where go from before
go from before peter one peter two two
peter three sure
the avengers
the avengers what's that
i love you
you're killing
shut
me
prove it
oh
nice
wow look how fun that looks yeah
oh so many people got to be putting
backgrounds on these
oh they look like they're having so much
fun
[Music]
ah that was that was so much fun i am
never going to
unappreciate the level of work it takes
to keep a straight face during so many
of these scenes with blue screens you
got to use your imagination so what's
always most striking to me is how when
you're doing these scenes that in the
movie they're so serious a lot of the
time and then you watch the blue person
you're like oh [ __ ] i had no idea how
much fun it might have been actually do
that scene it's just like the peter's
looking at each other when andrew's
doing the breathing i think that's the
shot from when they're looking at peter
where they think he's going to kill
green goblin and so that moment right
there something somewhat like the wire
effects of how complicated that must be
there were times where wired around like
why are they wired yeah and why is it so
hard for him to like get out like the
apparatus that you're in must be very
restricting and must be also very heavy
and yeah it looks surprisingly awkward
to be in the wire get up when in the
movie it's made to look like everything
is so fluid and smooth like that whole
thing with dr strange where he keeps
slipping on his way down and stuff like
that and it's it's fun to remember that
you know in these huge giant highly
polished movies that you know in the
day-to-day there is still a lot of just
really silly little things that happen
that you got to work around that you got
to problem solve yeah to see both
iterations too because you know like the
suit is iconic and to see like at which
points they're in the suits versus which
points they're in just motion capture
suits to be painted over with cgi
entirely later i feel like those things
are are fun and telling because
especially like you know with tom
holland's suit it seems like naturally
there would be a lot more digital
effects to go into that whereas yeah
with uh toby and andrew you know you get
the classic suits and there's something
that just feels like so much more fun
and tangible and to be there on the day
like in the actual suit has to do
something wholly different to your
performance or put you in a different
mindset and you know
the amount of bridging of the gap you
already have to do against these green
screens and stuff like that like these
are so fun but they're also still a
great kind of glimpse into the movie
magic that helps these things to soar to
the heights that they do you know yeah
and if anything what this really gave me
was i want an r-rated vulgar version of
spider-man no way home where all the
scenes where they use the f-bombs
throughout or those are the takes that i
really want to see the most because it's
so unusual to see them say the f-word
even though i've seen all these actors
do other things where they are swearing
or sometimes in interviews with their
swearing but when they're in costume
like i don't seem like doc ox hey father
and it just seems so strange to me so i
want to see like a lot more of that and
i was also surprised by the amount of
improv it seemed like some of those
scenes that were letting them improvise
like when he is saying like there's an
electric man there's a dinosaur she was
keeping a straight face for most of it
so i'm not surprised by how much improv
there is but i would like a cool
breakdown from john watson this scene
was improvised more that part was
improvised more i liked like the little
nuances the little touches those are
some of my favorite things of something
as simple as like a little andrew
garfield line i'm like i love you guys
of how he wanted to do that how he came
up with that line and so whatever other
little reaction responses like you know
freaking harrison ford and han solo
saying i know instead of i love you back
those are like the iconic [ __ ] and and i
feel like a movie like this it's
sprinkled throughout for so much of the
film and i want to see more of that but
hey man this behind the scenes i'm
really looking forward to did you guys
already make it pre-order i hope you
pre-ordered spider-man no way home
anyway thank you so much for being here
this was fun appreciate you guys sending
my way and uh thank you to walking dead
no man's land for sponsoring the video
don't know why you interrupted me there
but i'll take it i'll take it
i'll take it
[Music]